اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين سوريه يعيشون في
تركيا اليوم يقل هذا العدد بمعدل 22 الف
لاجئ شهريا اما بسبب انتقالهم الى بلد
ثالث واما بسبب العوده الى سوريا واما
بسبب حملات ترحيل
حسب ما يوثق ناشطون ومنظمات حقوقيه في حين
تقول الحكومه التركيه ان الحملات تشمل
المخالفين فقط مؤكده في الوقت نفسه وجود
اخطاء فرديه
سوريا سوريا
ثمان سنوات في ذروه وجودهم في تركيا لم
يبتعد اللاجئون عن اي قضيه سياسيه في هذا
البلد فهم ورقه المعارضه الاولى في
انتخابات البلديه عام 2019 ثم انتخابات
الرئاسه في 2023 ويدخلون على الخط ايضا في
المنافسه الحاده التي تسبق الانتخابات
البلديه القادمه في ربيع
وعشرين هذه الاجواء السلبيه مدفوعه باسئله
كثيره تطرحها الاطراف السياسيه من مختلف
التيارات لماذا لا يعود اللاجئون الى
بلدهم الم تنتهي الحرب ماذا عن المناطق
الامنه التي ترعاها تركيا في الشمال قبل
ان نبحث عن اجابات هذه الاسئله تعالوا
نحاول تفكيك عقده السوريين قبل عام 2011
الذي اشتعلت فيه الثوره نظام الاسد كان
السوريون يدخلون تركيا بالهويه الشخصيه
فقط هذه التسهيلات لم تغلي اكثر الشباب
السوري لاختيار تركيا وجهه للعمل او
التجاره او التعليم وكانت اعداد السوريين
في تركيا لا تزيد على اي جاليه عربيه اخرى
تقول البيانات الرسميه التركيه ان 94% من
اللاجئين اليوم في تركيا عاشوا اول عامين
من الحرب في بلادهم وهي المرحله التي شهدت
سيطره المعارضه السوريه على مساحات واسعه
من البلاد اما موجه الهجره الكبرى فكانت
في اواخر عام 2015 بعد اشهر من تدخل روسيا
لحمايه نظام الاسد وبعد اقل من عام على
دخول تنظيم الدوله طرفا ثالثا في هذا
الصراع
بزين عسكري
بصوتهم المنخفض ومساحتهم الضيقه جدا في
الاعلام التركي وبلغتهم التي تعلموها على
كبر يبذل السوريون جهدهم لايصال رسائل
تبرر وجودهم في هذا البلد لم ناتي هربا من
الحرب بل من نظام بشار الاسد لم يتوقف
عداد الموت لا شمالا ولا جنوبا هذه
الرسائل تترجمها تقارير للشبكه السوريه
لحقوق الانسان ومنظمتي العفو الدوليه
وهيوما رايتهوش يقول احدها ان من اصل 65
شخصا عادوا الى مناطق النظام في سوريا بين
عامي 2017
و21 قتل خمسه اشخاص خارج اطار القانون
واختفى 17 قصرا واعتقل 21 اخرون كل هذه
الانتهاكات حدثت على يد النظام السوري
الذي لا يعترف بتلك الجرائم لكنه يقر
بعجزه عن توفير ادنى الخدمات اللازمه
لعوده السوريين كيف نخلي لاجئ ان يعود من
دون ماء ولا كهرباء ولا مدارس ابنائه ولا
صح للعلاج اما في مناطق الشمال حيث تسيطر
فصائل معارضه متعدده بعضها مدعوم من تركيا
فيستبعد كثير من السوريين العوده لعدم
اقتناهم بوجود سلطه تضمن القانون واستقرار
الامن ولا يرى معظم اللاجئين ان شتاتهم
سينتهي بالعوده الى تلك المناطق التي
تعاني وضع اقتصاديا مترديا واكتظاظا بشريا
كبيره
لانه يعني في تجربه في بعض المدن تحررت
وما عاد فيها صراع
لكن ما في امان لانه ما فيها سلطه مركزيه
[موسيقى]